[Music]
you are good before I take any job I'll
look at it the same way that it takes to
make the bang positive versus negative
now you mix a little minimus with a
little bit of man and you get a reaction
a reaction is power it's moving fast and
it's moving away from you but it keeps
moving till it had some of that luck
evolved oh sure like a volleyball net
energy is moving away from you it's
called the positive pressure face but
there's also a negative pressure face
that part of a thing that sucks some of
the energy back toward you so you want
to make sure you always cut more
positive than negative or else you've
got to get out of the way fast
pulling on a job like this I got away
the positive versus the names of it
leave Logan suggests they give it it's a
plus a minus we get positive than
negative
all kind so all cash that's a positive
but a place like the track going to have
twenty times a secure you're a bank so
that's negative but they'll be a whole
mess of people walking around there
that's positive helps us blend in
they'll be metal detectors and cameras
you know recording every into the place
it's negative we can't bring anything
through that gates
no exposes no we don't want using
absolutely no guns
well I guess then that you Logan's
that's a positive so you will do which
one you love into busted me out of here
you